it has been a ratings bonanza this week
for dr. Phylis millions of tuned in for
his exclusive interview with John
Pinette Ramsay's brother Burke know a
lot of the fascination had to do with
Burke's mannerisms his expression when
talking about his sister's death is not
what most people would expect so dr.
Phil gave us some answers today hey we
can't find your sister what do you think
happened she's dead
many of you have commented on Burke's
smile this is anxiety he's socially
uncomfortable at some point you have to
move on he's not autistic he's not weird
he's not creepy he's just nervous while
the focus has been all about Burke's
smile his fidgeting and his nervous
laughs dr. Phil remains protective of
the 29 year old computer consultant who
works from home did you hit your sister
with a golf club not on purpose
she's standing behind me and I know that
he's kind of a loner you know when
people are anxious they do different
things you know maybe they kind of pull
on their hair or they you know fiddle
around or whatever for him it's a
nervous smile I want them to focus on
finding the real killer and not making
up bogus theories about me my parents
not much is known about Burke Phil won't
even disclose where he lives to protect
his privacy but one thing he revealed
Burke has moved on and even found love
he's a relationship with a very nice
young woman and he has a good
relationship with his father they're not
together all the time
they live half a country apart it's been
20 years since this happened and in that
time Burke's never been in trouble with
the law
he's never he's never had any problem
with assault or violence or anything
like that I'm he's totally consistent
with him not being a suspect in our
final episode what you're going to hear
is Burke has a very specific theory
about who killed his sister and that
final episode airs Monday on dr. Phil